listen to film courage
OMG
my support system is just pretty much me
and you know whoever's out there my you
know my following and you know my
friends obviously they support whatever
I do you know and you know my family
took some extent now that you know they
know I'm very passionate about what I do
you know also trying to maintain the
family business also and you know just
you know making sure my education
doesn't go to waste so yeah now I'm
still fascinated by the fact that you
said that I mean you wrote a script you
wrote it at age 17 yeah and it was it
was picked up by touchstone I mean it
that did that give you the early
confidence to say yes you know I can
proceed from this point forward was that
was that kind of thing that said you
know what I'm going to keep on this
track it definitely showed me that I had
a talent for it you know especially
because you know I wasn't a professional
writer I didn't graduate with my masters
in English or anything like that or
screenwriting or anything like that